- I don't know if you've
read, Carl Jung said
that the greatest danger
that humanity faces
is not from any external
force like natural disasters
or diseases or pandemics.
He said the greatest
danger that humanity faces
is a collective psychosis.
So to some extent, I see it
happening, not quite as extreme
yet as in places like
Maoist China or Cambodia
where 1/3 of the population
got murdered in Cambodia.
Absurd, totally absurd ideas
taking over people's minds.
For example, in Cambodia, we
were there a few years ago,
at the time of Pol Pot,
the Cambodian mad dictator,
anybody who could read
and write or anybody,
if you wear glasses, you
were an enemy of the people
because you were regarded as the oppressor
and likely to be killed.
You had to show your hands.
You're not doing manual work,
you're one of the enemies of the people.
(warm instrumental music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is one of the most widely recognized
spiritual teachers on the planet.
His book, "The Power of Now"
sold 12 million, that's million copies,
and the followup, "A New Earth"
sold over 15 million copies.
Both have been translated
in over 50 languages.
My friend Eckhart Tolle, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you, Dave, nice to see you again.
- It's great to talk to you.
As my audience knows,
we are at the beginning
of August right now,
and I am technically off the grid.
I am in an undisclosed
location with no technology,
no phone, no computer,
no news, no nothing.
So we're taping this at the end of July,
and I thought you would
be the right person
to sort of kick this month off with.
So before we get to sort
of the off the grid stuff
and digital detox, I wanted
to ask you just sort of,
what do you make of the
spiritual health of the planet
in this last year and a half,
this sort of crazy year and a half
that we've all had to deal with?
- Yes, I believe crazy
is quite a good word
to describe it in many ways.
There's been many collective challenges.
The main one is the
virus and the lockdowns
and various other challenges.
I've had this strange feeling,
idea in the past few months
that a certain segment of humanity
is losing the ability to think rationally.
There is a decrease in, I call
it IQ or whatever it may be.
There's a diminishment of
rational faculty as reflected
in many ways on mainstream
media, social media and so on.
And another segment of humanity
is actually becoming more aware,
more aware, more conscious,
is not drawn into the regressive phase
that some of humanity
may be going through.
It's not unusual for humanity
to occasionally collectively
regress to a lower state of consciousness.
It just happened whenever
a country or collective
has been taken over by an almost,
one could say toxic ideology
that has completely taken possession
of millions of people's minds.
Look at of course, National
Socialism in Germany.
The Maoist Cultural
Revolution was quite crazy.
What happened in Cambodia under Pol Pot.
Totally crazy ideas invaded
millions of people's minds
and reduced their ability
to actually engage in rational thinking.
And things that happened,
for example, in Maoist China
during the Cultural Revolution,
children reporting on their parents,
when they were angry with their parents.
All they had to do is go to
school and report their parents,
that they had said something
against the government.
The parents would be taken
away and never seen again.
They went around public parks
in big cities in China tearing out flowers
because beauty was
regarded as bourgeoisie.
You had to kill your
pets, your dogs and cats.
And these are just a few
examples of totally toxic
and irrational thoughts
taking over people's minds.
So that's, to some extent,
I've been seeing this
happening collectively,
not just in one country,
in quite a few Western,
many Western countries that I'm aware of.
But it has not affected everybody.
Some people have managed to remain aware.
They have not been,
one could say, infected
by what one could perhaps
call a mental virus
or mental viruses that
reduce people's ability
to actually see reality.
Reality then gets
distorted through the veil
of these mental viruses that
have taken over people's minds.
This is a more serious pandemic
than anything that happens
on the physical level
as far as pandemics are
concerned, the actual viruses.
Actually, you might, I
don't know if you've read,
Carl Jung said that the greatest
danger that humanity faces
is not from any external
force like natural disasters
or diseases or pandemics.
He said the greatest
danger that humanity faces
is a collective psychosis.
So to some extent, I see it
happening, not quite as extreme
yet as in places like
Maoist China or Cambodia
where 1/3 of the population
got murdered in Cambodia.
Absurd, totally absurd ideas
taking over people's minds.
For example, in Cambodia, we
were there a few years ago,
at the time of Pol Pot,
the Cambodian mad dictator,
anybody who could read
and write or anybody,
if you wear glasses, you
were an enemy of the people
because you were regarded as the oppressor
and likely to be killed.
You had to show your hands.
You're not doing manual work,
you're one of the enemies of the people.
They sent them away.
1/3 or more of the
population got exterminated
through insanity taking
over people's minds.
You no longer can see reality as it is.
The famous example from "1984," Orwell,
you have to believe that
two plus two equals five.
- Right.
- And if you don't believe it,
then you are the enemy.
- Which is sort of what
we're being told these days
from some pretty powerful people
and some pretty powerful people
that are pushing bad ideas.
But I suspect that you think
if more people lived in the moment,
if more people harness
the power of now that
that would be the best
inoculation from this mind virus.
- Yes, inoculation to have,
and inoculation is one word one could use.
The key is immunity.
I think I would use immunity.
The key is what we could call awareness,
or as I'm just calling it, presence.
Awareness or presence
is nothing complicated.
It's the ability to become
aware of your thoughts
so you can take a step back and to observe
what thoughts are going through your head.
For example, when this ability arises,
I call that the beginning
of a spiritual awakening.
Spiritual is no longer
being completely trapped
and identified with the
movement of thinking.
This is particularly important now.
The danger of infection, viral
infection on a mental level
has always been there, but
it's now becoming magnified
by the technology that we now have.
A toxic idea, a toxic thought
can spread like wildfire
through the internet
within a few days and can take possession
or become lodged in
countless people's minds.
And once a thought has become lodged,
then it will attract associated thoughts
that resonate with it and
then suddenly you see reality
through the veil of that
irrational thinking,
but you don't know that this is happening
because you do not have
the immunity of awareness.
Awareness is the ability to
know what your mind is doing.
It's also, for example, the ability,
I think it was Aristotle
who talked about the ability
of having two conflicting
thoughts in your mind
without necessarily
identifying with either.
That implies there is an awareness there.
Without awareness, one thought
will draw you in completely.
You will identify with it completely,
and then everything
else is then disregarded
or regarded as threatening.
The egoic self, it identifies
with one particular position.
And this is just one example.
There are many examples one could give.
It identifies with one position,
and then everything else
is regarded as whatever the term is.
What are the favorite terms these days?
Disinformation or whatever,
anyone who disagrees
with my mental position,
that's disinformation.
We know many examples of that.
- So what's the best way to
immunize yourself against that?
I mean, I think about that all the time.
I try to bring information to people
in as honest and decent way as possible.
And sometimes I think I'm pretty decent,
probably sometimes not so decent,
but I have no doubt that
I have that veil as well.
And I have probable blind
spots due to my history
or whatever it might be.
How do you actually climb out of something
if you're unaware of it at some level?
- Yes, to become aware of one's thinking,
there's no easy answer to that.
To many people it happens naturally.
For example, it tends to
happen sometimes to people
on a personal level whose
thinking becomes so negative
about the, in other words, the
stories they tell themselves.
Let's talk about
narratives that people have
in their heads, in their minds.
My life is so dreadful
or I've been treated so
unfairly by society and life
and I've had, everything
bad always happens to me.
I know these things
because when I was young,
I had similar thoughts in my mind,
very negative, negative narratives.
And the more negative narratives
you have, for some people,
it's the negative narratives
about the world out there,
which is, everything is evil
and they're out to sabotage me and so on.
Or the negative narrative
may be about myself,
there's something wrong with me.
Whatever it may be, it
leads to an enormous amount
of suffering, emotional suffering
because the emotion is
usually a reflection
of what you're telling
yourself in your mind
creates a reflection
on the emotional level.
So if your narrative is very negative,
you then experience very negative
emotions, anger, sadness,
resentment, or if your
narrative is very much directed
towards the future, the fearful future,
then there's a lot of anxiety and fear
because the future is so uncertain.
And so people who go into a
lot of suffering, at some point
they sometimes realize that
the suffering they experience
is actually produced by their own minds.
For example, somebody might
suddenly wake up and say,
for the past few hours I've been engaged
in negative thinking about
myself and the world.
Wow, isn't that amazing?
That I have these thoughts
that come back again.
They recur again and again,
thoughts about myself,
things I tell myself about myself.
And so these thoughts are
creating so much suffering.
You can stand back and see it.
Well, I'm so negative.
Why am I always criticizing people?
Why am I always complaining
about everything?
This is the beginning of becoming
aware of what's happening.
Complaining is a big pattern
in many people's minds.
They love complaining.
Complaining about what's out there,
complaining about my life
and pointing about them,
complaining, and I'm not
talking about complaining
where you have the ability
to change a situation.
Then sometimes it's good to speak out
when there's possibility of change.
But many cases, people just complain
because it makes the ego feel bigger
because the more I complain about others,
the bigger my ego feels
because I'm right and they are all wrong
and the ego loves to be right.
- You're perfectly spelling out
exactly why I get off social
media because we all suffer.
We all suffer from that.
If I get a lot of retweets,
it has a certain dopamine effect to me,
or I sometimes I open it up
and I'll look for negative comments
even though I don't consider
myself a negative person.
- Yes, now, but a very important thing.
When you have interviews
or dialogues with people,
there's usually, there's
a background field
of a peaceful coming together.
There's a background field of,
there's a certain connective.
Even if your opinion and the
person you're interviewing,
maybe have very different viewpoints,
very different thoughts, nevertheless,
you are not so identified
with a viewpoint,
the mental position, that
anybody who questions
your viewpoint is unconsciously
regarded as an enemy
that needs to be defeated so
that you have an awareness,
perhaps you don't call it awareness.
When you conduct interviews,
there's still a background field of peace.
There is not antagonism.
I observed the same, I was
very unhappy to observe,
Russell Brand recently
interviewed Shapiro.
What's his-
- Oh, Ben Shapiro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's his name?
- Ben Shapiro.
- And there was a lot of disagreement,
but there was a mutual respect.
- They come from completely
different positions.
Russell Brand is on the left,
obviously Ben Shapiro is on the right.
And then they reversed it later.
Ben Shapiro had him on his show
and it was really very pleasant to watch.
They were both able to express
clearly their viewpoints
and their mental positions
without attacking each other at all.
So there was an undercurrent of awareness,
as I would call it, which is
a dimension of consciousness
that is extremely important for humans
to realize within themselves
because if you're not aware
of what your mind is doing
so there's some separation
from the mental position,
which is the thought and
who you are, who you are,
is the aware presence in the
background that frees you
from being possessed by thoughts,
by narrative space, by mental positions.
And so that takes the ego
out of the interaction
and then you can have
a fruitful interaction.
So you don't need to
give up your view points
or your mental positions,
but not be totally identified with it
so that anybody who questions
it becomes your enemy.
- It's so interesting because obviously
you're not a political beast,
but what you're saying
here is so applicable
to everything that
everyone's fighting about
sort of politically these days.
But I want to ask you one other thing
about the state of the
world before we move
into a little bit of the
technology part of this
and the off the grid sense, which is that
I think you know a bit about my story.
I used to consider myself an atheist
for probably most of my adult
life and I don't anymore
for probably about four or five years.
I would say I'm more of a believer now
than I've ever been in my adult life.
And I think that is
connected to my ability
to sort of stay sane within a
very polarized political time
and as someone that puts
their opinions out there.
And I wonder what you think about that,
just sort of what the state
of belief is at the moment
when we factor in this last
year and a half and lockdowns
and fearfulness of a disease,
and if I walk outside, this
might happen and, and so on.
- Yes, it's the belief really should lead
to a little bit of a deeper realization.
Belief alone is fine.
To believe that your life
has a purpose is good.
That there is a greater purpose to life
than just your personal life.
And somehow your personal
life needs to be in alignment
with a greater purpose
that pervades the universe.
There is an intelligence
that is transcendent
to sense perceived reality,
that is beyond that.
An intelligence that
manifests itself in this world
but is also beyond this world.
Now, whether we call that vast,
inconceivable intelligence
God or the divine
or no name at all doesn't really matter.
So it's good to believe that it's there.
And then the next step is
to have a little bit of
an experience to experience
that which lies beyond the world
of form, which is physical
forms and even mental forms.
And that which lies
beyond the world of form
is this transcendent dimension
that humans can sense within themselves.
It sounds perhaps a
little abstract right now,
but you can sense it, for
example, in between two thoughts
when one thought comes to an end
and there's a moment of clear awareness.
You're just, you're looking around.
Sometimes this happens
when you're out in nature.
You're able to stop thinking for a moment,
but you don't lose consciousness.
There's still an awareness there.
And you perceive everything
against this background of awareness.
That is the light of consciousness.
This is why, again, it does
connect us with religion.
Jesus said to his disciples,
"You are the light of the world."
He's talking to everybody
when he said that.
Now, this doesn't mean you are
a very special human being,
you're more special than others
because the people he talked to
were not special on a worldly level.
They were not VIPs.
They were simpler people, but he said,
"You are the light of the world."
In another gospel, he
said it about himself.
He said, "I am the light of the world."
So both statements he said.
Now what does that mean?
If you are the light of the world,
the light in you is the consciousness,
the consciousness with which
the world is perceived,
the consciousness without which
no sense perception would be possible.
The consciousness without which
no thought would be possible.
So you are this light of consciousness.
And to sense yourself as the consciousness
that is far more vast than the personality
which consists of thought,
movement, to sense yourself
for a moment sense that inner
stillness but not go to sleep.
No, very alert, sense
that inner stillness.
Then you can sense the dimension,
the inner dimension that is
deeper than the personality.
And that is the light of
the world that emanates.
We're going a bit deep
now, but let's do it.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- That is the light of the world.
The light of consciousness that emanates
from the transcendent source of all lives.
So to me, God is the
transcendent source of all lives.
God does not have a
location in space or time.
God transcends space and time, but God,
it's a bit like the Sun in
the sense perceived world.
The Sun emanates life.
It emanates light which is
life continuously, it emanates.
Now, let's imagine that
you are a ray of sunlight.
And suddenly you realize
that who or what you are
emanates from the Sun.
Before you didn't know it
because you thought you
were a disconnected ray,
just a little spark disconnected.
And then you become still for a moment
and you sense the connectedness
to something much deeper than the person.
So just a moment of stillness.
In one of the Psalms in
the Old Testament, it says,
be still and know that I am God.
You can only know God in the stillness.
When you become still then suddenly,
to go back to the analogy,
the ray of sunlight
realizes its connectedness
and oneness with the Sun
And some of the mystics who
discovered that in themselves
suddenly said, I am God.
That's not advisable to do.
And then we usually,
people didn't like that.
So because the ray of sunlight,
yes, it's eternally connected.
It's an emanation of the
Sun, but it's not the Sun.
You are an emanation or your
consciousness is an emanation
of the Godhead or God,
but you are not God,
but you're connected to,
you are one with God and you're not,
seemingly paradoxical or
contradictory statements.
So just the belief is good.
And then the belief can lead to something
a little deeper than just the beliefs.
And then you can rest in
that sense of connectedness
to something that
transcends the personality.
You rest in that.
And that is what is called,
to me, that is the true meaning of faith.
Faith to me is not just
an ideological belief
that this is the case or the belief
that a certain story from
the past actually happened.
Faith is trust.
And the trust comes with the realization
that there's more to you
than just the personality,
the person, and to be rooted
in this trust is inner peace.
And then you can breathe more clearly.
There are people who are
extremely knowledgeable
about spirituality and everything else,
but they have never gone
that little step further
from recognizing the truth
on an intellectual level,
which is good, to going
a little bit further
and realize the truth
experientially in their own lives.
And that frees them from fear and anxiety.
It's a wonderful
liberation to realize that,
maybe not continuously,
but you have more and more,
you realize there is more
to you than meets the eye,
so to speak, that you are
not the physical body,
you're not your mind even.
There's an invisible presence
that is the essence of who you are.
And it's vital for humans to realize that.
I believe that's the next step
now that old-fashioned
religions in many countries
are beginning to disappear,
the old religion,
but in a way I can see why many humans
cannot believe these stories anymore,
but we have to be very careful that the,
what is the expression?
Throw out the baby with the bath water.
- Right.
- Because there's something
extremely valuable there still.
This is why I often refer back to
that it just needs to
be more than ideology.
We need to take one step
further into that realization.
So this is a, we could talk
about this for a long time,
but I don't know whether
this will help anybody,
but I hope so.
- Well, first off, of course,
it's gonna help people,
but really you're describing
my own personal journey almost to a tee.
And you're actually also describing
why this will be my fifth
year doing this off the grid
August situation because
it was on the first one
where I was sitting on a beach
and David kept saying to me
for days, "Why aren't you reading a book?
You're just sitting and
staring at the ocean."
And I said, "That's actually
what I need right now."
And it was truly in that
moment when the thought
popped into my mind
that I'm not an atheist.
And I would say in the
five years since then
have been the most sort
of rewarding and enriching
and full years that
I've had on this planet.
So I wonder, to connect
that to what I'm doing
with this month, I
suppose someone like you
kinda digs something like this,
the idea that someone could
put down their devices.
And I wonder, what do
you think just in general
about a world that is
so obsessively connected
to other people's thoughts all day long.
- Yes, that's good.
So although this excessive
identification with thinking
and overthinking, excessive thinking
has been there for a long time,
long before we came up with these devices,
but these devices amplify
the human tendency to engage
or indulge in excessive thinking
and problem-making thinking
rather than constructive
thinking, focused thinking.
So what you are doing
is very, very helpful
because you are basically
having a period of,
we could call it decluttering your mind.
You declutter your mind.
And this is necessary because
our mind, most people's minds
have never been as
cluttered as they are now.
Cluttered means there's a
continuous input of stuff
that comes in through the devices.
The messages come in,
Facebook posts, tweets,
and continuously the devices
demand your attention
and say, this is important.
And a lot of it is not important.
But as we all know, there's
an addictive quality to it.
It draws your attention to it.
And then every time it
draws your attention,
you add to the clutter of your mind.
A lot of not is not constructive.
A lot of it is just random.
People often see people,
they get out their phones
and they do this random scrolling.
I can see it's random,
there's nothing specific,
but they think they have to do it
because everybody else
is doing it around them.
Wherever you are these days,
people are engaging with this,
and they're continuously
taking in thoughts from others.
And as we said before, some
of these thoughts may be toxic
and they may easily become
lodged in your mind.
So to declutter is extremely important.
And you can see if you're
even just not using a device
for a day, for many people
it's very, very hard.
And some think they can
do it, but they can't
so they are truly addicted.
Now, when you declutter your mind,
first of all, you put down
your phone, you don't use it.
Not everybody can do it
for a whole month like you.
- Of course, of course.
- But I recommend to everybody
to have certain periods of
time when they do not engage.
So for example, in your
bedroom might be a good place
to try out for not
engaging with any device.
Certain periods of time,
when you go out into nature,
be there rather than carry that thing
and every time it makes a
noise, you still look up
and you're still, even while
you're surrounded by beauty
and aliveliness, you're
still engaging with this
or everything that you are looking at
is an opportunity for an Instagram post.
And you're just looking,
look, I'm here now.
Me here, me there and
then you send it out.
So you never again become
completely trapped in the mind
more than even, with these
devices I'm very concerned
about youngsters these
days who grow up with them.
Perhaps this is the first generation.
I don't know, the first iPhone
was maybe 12, 13 years
ago, something like that.
And these many youngsters,
for many youngsters
the virtual reality is more
important to them than all this,
and this is a very dangerous development.
They lose the ability to
relate to other humans.
They spend several hours
per day on devices,
whereas before they would go
out, running around outside,
playing their games, creative,
coming up with new games,
creative activities, relating
to nature, climbing up trees.
Yes, it's a little bit of risky.
You might fall down, but again,
our society is obsessed
with safety and security.
But anyway, let's not go
there right now. (laughs)
So I'm very concerned.
It's not inconceivable that it could have
such a detrimental effect on consciousness
that within two generations,
it could lead to the
breakdown of civilization
because humans would no longer
be able to creatively think,
focus on a specific
problem for long enough
to find a solution, connect
with a deeper intelligence
that is necessary to do
anything creative in this world,
to give attention to something
for a certain period of time
rather than have short attention periods.
You can't focus on anything for very long.
How can you solve a problem
if you cannot look at it,
face it, and then become
still for a moment,
activate your deep intelligence
and then see what the solution might be.
So if we lose the ability,
it's the parents' responsibility
to limit their children's
time with these devices.
And I would suggest periodically
take them out into nature
without these things so that
they don't lose their ability
to connect with nature.
It's so important to connect with nature
because you find sanity there.
That was my saving thing
when I was a child.
I would get on my bike.
I was very unhappy in my home environment.
It was very dysfunctional.
My parents couldn't help it.
They were just in the grip of dysfunction
and their parents had been
in the grip of dysfunction.
And so I would get on my
bike, go out into nature,
like a 15-minute bike ride.
Not magnificent, fantastic nature,
just normal fields, groves of trees.
And there I would suddenly
get off my bike and say, "Ah."
I didn't have any devices to distract me.
There weren't any.
I would actually be there and look.
And I would often say to myself,
this will always be here.
I didn't know what that meant.
I could feel that nature
was more important
than the man-made world,
the human-made world.
The human-made world for
me was a very unhappy one.
And the natural world
was where I found liberation
whenever I went there.
But if I'd had these phones,
I would have carried that with me
and probably no longer be
able to really relate to it.
- You'll be happy to know
that by the time we air this,
I will probably be sitting in a tree house
in a rain forest, doing exactly this.
I mean, this is exactly
why I wanted to talk to you
before I went off the grid.
But you mentioned something
that I thought was really
interesting which is
that it's not just that
we're being inundated
with other people's thoughts,
but that we're never
giving ourself the space,
the moments where in the
old days, if you said
you were gonna meet your
friend at a restaurant, well,
if you went to the restaurant
first and they weren't there,
you might have to sit for a few moments.
You might have to perhaps
talk to somebody else,
but you might have to just
stand and look around and think
and see people where now
we don't do that at all.
What do we all immediately do?
So it's really about creating
that space in many ways
is more important than inoculating
or immunizing the thoughts.
That's almost the obvious
one, it's the other piece.
- Exactly, that's very important.
And that is something that anybody can do
to create that space.
It's very true what you say.
Almost nowhere do you see people,
wherever people congregate
at airports, cafes, benches, park benches,
wherever they are, most of them
are getting engaged with their
devices, it's incredible.
So to consciously decide
not to engage whenever,
for example, you're waiting
for something or someone.
And a lot of the time we are waiting
for things in this world.
You're waiting for somebody,
as you said an example,
for a friend to arrive
and you're sitting there,
why do you need to engage?
Why can't you just be,
contemplate the world, look around
and be, and enjoy being in
the moment in this moment.
And those are the states
where creative insights often arise.
If you don't give yourself
space, it's very unlikely
that any creative
realizations, ideas, insights,
realizations will arise in you
because your mind is too cluttered.
So if you give yourself
space, it's more likely
that you will become more
creative as a human being
because that's where these
things, without space,
good new ideas, insights,
and realizations don't arise.
There's no room for them to arise.
So give yourself, a wonderful example,
you're waiting for somebody, just be there
unless there's actually
something to communicate.
Maybe he's texting you, he
says, I'll be five minutes late.
Fine, okay, and then you put it away.
I often recommend anytime you're waiting,
just be conscious of yourself
in the present moment.
Elevators even, you press the button,
elevator, and you're waiting.
Why do you need to get out
your phone for a thought
half a minute or one minute, why?
You don't need, just
be, breathe consciously.
Have a little bit of
inner space, inner space.
The loss of inner space
is a terrible loss,
and that is the opposite of clutter.
Make sure that you become
aware of this inner space
where there's no clutter.
There's just a lovely, aware presence
when you contemplate the world around you,
you're aware perhaps
that you're breathing.
You're aware even perhaps
that your body is alive.
You can sense that your
body is alive, inner space.
Without spaciousness, your
life is very unsatisfying.
The most satisfying thing in
life is inner spaciousness,
and many humans don't have that anymore.
- And we all know that it's true.
If we would take that
moment to think about it,
what you're describing,
we all know is true.
You know, in the years
that I've done this,
when I come back in
September, I always notice
I have a certain force field
where I'm able to put
the device down more.
I'm able to pay less
attention, but then of course,
you know, the news starts again
or there's an election
or something happened.
And then it gets sort
of smaller and smaller.
But I'm wondering as
you're discussing this,
how much of this is just
that we have to battle
what our own nature is in a way,
that we have to battle what the ego is?
So for example, if you go
to a concert for a musician
or a band that you love,
instead of just being there
and just being there,
we're all taking the video,
we're all taking the pictures
'cause we want the likes and all that.
And that we're actually sort
of denigrating the thing
that gives us that
transcendent experience.
- [Eckhart] Yes.
- So we're battling
something within ourselves.
- Yes, it's certain conditioned patterns
that we kind of collectively
inherit where it's,
we're born into this world.
And at an early age, we
already become conditioned
by these collective
patterns that are part,
some belong to our family and background,
some belong to the general
culture that we grow up in.
So we become conditioned,
and to become aware of
one's own conditioning,
and again, the key word is aware.
If you become aware of your conditioning,
you're no longer totally in
the grip of your conditioning.
It may still operate, yes,
but you're one foot out
and one foot in the
conditioning, if you are aware.
And the example you gave
is also interesting.
Whenever people see
something, the thing is there,
they need to videotape, video or take
for selfies or snapshot.
So many people have lost the ability
to experience something
because everything that arises
is looked at as a possibility
for a photo or video.
And everything is experienced
through the screen.
When people go on
vacation often you can see
that they walk around maybe
the most magnificent place.
And instead of experiencing fully,
they experience it through this.
And perhaps the idea is, when
I get home and I look at this,
then I'll be able to
experience it fully, and-
(Dave laughing)
You can't do that either
- And it never, it never works that way.
It never works that way.
We're trying to hold onto something
that we're not fully
grasping in the first place.
- Yes, and of course
obviously it's nice sometimes
to be able to film something,
it's sometimes nice.
I, sometimes, one of my favorite
subjects for taking photos
is the sky, I love the
sky and the different,
the clouds and the different formations.
I have hundreds of photos of
the sky that I take on my phone
but I'm not absorbed by it.
I look at the sky maybe for five minutes,
I enjoy the beauty of it.
And then I get out my phone and I think,
wow, this is so wonderful and that's fine.
But I'm not treating it
as a photo opportunity
or a selfie opportunity.
Not that there's anything
wrong with occasional selfies,
but if the whole thing
takes over your life,
then that is dreadful.
- Right, I have a feeling
I wouldn't see you
wandering down the street taking selfies
with the clouds as the
less important part.
- I always say that the first, you know,
the myth of the ancient Greek
myth of Narcissus, the man,
this is where the term
narcissism comes from which,
narcissism being an extreme form of ego.
So Narcissus was a beautiful young man.
He was very happy.
And one day he was walking
and he saw a pool of water.
This is of course a time,
there were not any mirrors at that time.
In a pool of water he
saw his own reflection.
And the story goes,
says he fell in love
with his own reflection.
Better way of putting it is,
he became obsessed with
his own reflection.
And from then on, he became very unhappy
and his life didn't go well after that.
We don't need to go into
what happened to him,
but it wasn't good.
Now, this is a symbolic way of expressing
what happened to human consciousness
when the ego developed.
The ego is an image of
who you are in your mind.
It's a self image.
And when Narcissus saw himself,
the myth is a symbolic expression
of what happened to human consciousness.
As the ego developed,
then you'd suddenly have
an image of who you are.
I call it the first selfie
ever was when Narcissus
saw his own reflection
in the pool of water.
And this also, the
living through a persona,
which a persona, it's where
the word person comes from.
And the Latin word persona
actually means mask.
Living through a mental
image of who you are
and projecting this mental
image, that was already there
before we came up with all these devices.
But now it's become
amplified because many,
especially many young people,
they live through Facebook and Instagram,
and they create an image for themselves
that they project out into the world.
And it totally bears little resemblance
to who they actually are.
Now there's the added thing,
they can use filters and Photoshop.
Everybody can look beautiful.
Even I could look beautiful
with a little bit of that filter.
And often you wouldn't recognize these
if you saw them in the
street, totally distorted,
but they live through it.
It becomes more important to
them than their own being.
And ultimately it makes
humans very unhappy to live-
- Well, I realized.
I mean, that in many ways
is why I wanted to start doing this
because I realized as someone
that talks to the camera
and people say nice things
to me and, you know,
I get traction on Twitter
and all of those things,
I felt that I was not, I
wasn't trying to control it,
but it was becoming
sort of bigger than me,
which is why I want to do this.
So actually I only want
to ask you one more thing
'cause I want to be
respectful of your time.
But for most of my audience
what I sense people are
going through right now
is they're deeply worried
that the world that they knew
is disappearing at a very rapid rate.
You sort of hinted at something
like that at the beginning.
That the things that they
cared about about freedom
and the individual, that
these things are going away
and it's being amplified by social media
and bad political leaders
and everything else.
What would you say is a way to battle it
without becoming consumed by it?
That's what I try to do
on my show all the time.
I always try to do it with
a little bit of a smile
and a little sense of humor
because I don't want people to be crazy,
but I'm obviously not perfect at this.
What would you say to the average person
that wants to be aware?
They want to be engaged in
current events and politics
but also don't want to give
their life to it at the expense
of everything else that
you've discussed here.
- Yes, do everything with awareness
so that instead of being reactive,
let's say you see
somebody posting something
and you feel you want to reply.
Don't be reactive and attack somebody
that you have never even met.
And don't equate somebody's
perhaps erroneous opinion
with who they actually are.
I think it may be, if you
feel called upon to do that,
it may be good to point
out what you regard
as irrational statements
that are irrational,
point out viewpoints
that you think are toxic
without attacking the human
being that has these viewpoints.
You can attack opinions and viewpoints
or show them that they are erroneous
without making the people who have them
into absolute evil beings.
To separate what happens
on the level of mind
from the human being underneath.
It's easier to do that
when you're actually meeting a human being
because you can see there's the,
I sometimes call it the
human and the being.
Everybody is a human being.
The human is the conditioned
mind, the personality,
the conditioned entity is a human.
And the being is the
consciousness that's beyond that.
That's the deeper being,
that's the, a monk would say
the true human that's a child of God.
Every human is a child of God,
but the overlay may be very,
very dense of conditioning.
That's the human level.
It's easier not to lose
sight of the being dimension
in another human when you
see them face to face.
Then perhaps you can still sense it.
But when you're only
relating to abstract words,
often, on the screen,
then you confuse what's
produced by the human level.
You lose sight of their being completely.
There's an observed
statement that you read
and you feel that you
want to clarify that.
It's perfectly fine to do that
if you feel called upon to do it,
if you think it has a purpose to do that.
Sometimes it might,
sometimes it might not,
without making the person
who has that opinion
into an enemy, although he or she
will try to make you
into an enemy, of course.
In other words, don't
contribute to the insanity.
Bring sanity into this world.
Do not allow the insanity to pull you in
because that can easily happen.
It pulls you in and then
the monster that you,
in other words, I don't
remember who said it-
- If you gaze to, yeah.
- When you fight monsters
be careful that you
don't become a monster.
Or Nietzsche said, "When
you look into the abyss
then the abyss also looks into
you" or something like that.
So that is certainly the case.
So I think to bear in mind,
to bring sanity into
this world is your job.
To bring sanity into,
well, that in many ways
is going in the opposite direction
is becoming more and more crazy.
So it's doubly important
for you to represent,
to embody the sanity and always be aware
of the gravitational pull of craziness,
which is there all around you.
And the gravitational pull,
it's the reactivity that comes.
You don't need that.
Give yourself a moment
when you feel reactive.
Before you post anything,
give yourself a few minutes
to calm down, become present,
and then see what useful
contribution you could make
to this particular
discussion on what it may be.
So who said it?
I don't remember the famous phrase,
be the change that you
want to see in this world.
Maybe it was Nelson Mandela.
I don't remember quite who
said it, but it doesn't matter.
So if you want more sanity in this world,
and if you see that there's a
lot of insanity in this world,
then it's your job not to
become part of the insanity.
You cannot fight insanity
with more insanity.
So be aware, be present, be conscious,
and don't be totally identified
with your mental positions,
but express them clearly.
But realize who you are is far deeper
than your mental positions.
They are relatively important
but not absolutely important.
One thing that's absolutely
important is your being.
There's the human and there's
the being, you are both.
And you can exist in both
dimensions consciously
in the being and be
active on the human level
without losing yourself
on the human level,
which is the mind, which is the world,
which is the internet,
that's all the human level.
So be a real human being
so that the two dimensions
are active in you.
- Well, Eckhart, you know, it's funny.
I asked you to explain it for my audience,
and I know you were talking
directly to them there,
but I genuinely felt like you
were talking directly to me.
And that's exactly why I do
this off the grid for 30 days.
And I give you my word that
I will be trying to connect
to my human and my being.
And what a great way to leave
for me so I thank you so much,
and I promise you that
I'm gonna incorporate that
even further when I get back in the fall.
- Right, and have a wonderful
time on your retreat.
- Thank you, my friend.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics, check out our
full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.